本日はなんと
100万円企画第3弾！！
遊園地を
貸切っておりまーーーーす！！
・・・パチパチパチ
（気まずい拍手）
いぇーい（笑）
つってもバンジーがしたいだけなんですけどね
ただいまよみうりランドを貸し切って
おります
貸切ってしかできない企画って
何かなと思ったんですけど…
ある乗り物を独占的に乗り続けられるって言う…
なかなか普段だとできない。
他のお客さんがいると迷惑かかっちゃうんで、
なかなかできないようなことができる
と思ったんで
今回はこちら！
バンジージャンプでございます（苦）
ちょっと検証したいことがありまして、
マサキ「はい」
バンジージャンプ
やったことあります？
マサキ「ない」
あぁっ（苦）
とにかく怖いんですよ
バンジージャンプって
で、今回僕が検証したいのは…
俺、バンジージャンプ何回乗ったら
怖くなくなるんだろうな？って
マサキ
(・∀・)ﾆﾔﾆﾔ
今回の検証では
「バンジージャンプは何回乗ったら
怖くなくなるのか」
検証していきたいと思います
マサキ「ハィ…」
「頑張れ！」
がんばります！
彼で一回どれくらい怖いのかを
一回、見てみましょう
マサイ「死んじゃう・・・」
↑しなないからｗ
バンジージャンプ一丁！
マサキ「何で！？俺ほんとにこれからやんの？」
そう。
えっ！高くない？ほんとに。
えー怖い(-_-;)
怖い、怖い、マジで怖い、、、
ほんとに怖い　ほんっとどうしよう
怖いよー
ふ～えっふん！（くしゃみ）
は「毛玉がすごい・・・」
マ「ねぇ…ねぇ…」
マ「ねぇ！こわい！」
怖い？
気取ってやがるｗ
これが最後の、、、
生前最後の映像かもしれないｗ
あぁ！！　こわい！！
３，２，１
バンジー！！
ヴァヌッッッ！
ヌファァァァッ！！！
ヴゥォウォッ！！
Why?!
訳）なぜ？！
イャハァハァ～ッ！
どうだった？
こぉぉわぁぁいぃぃぃぃ（震）
普通に飛ぶとこれぐらい怖いんですよ
バンジージャンプって。
この恐怖心が
何回やったらなくなるか
マサキ「なくなんないよこｒ…」
は「では行こう！！」
やべぇ！やべぇ！
うわぁ！待って！
うおっ！チクチクしてるね…
あ、待って！
ほんとに怖い！！
無理ィィィィィイ！！
待って、
ヤバい、ヤバい、ヤバいっ・・・
あ''～まって怖い！！
あ～待って～やばい
待ってヤバい！怖い！怖い！
「誰がー！助けでー！」」
うぅぅうぇええええ
こええええええ！
うわっ！うわっ！
あっ！あっ！あっ！あっ！
うわヤバイ！！
だれかー！
うわーっ！
よく飛んだね？！？！
マサキ「いやマジで怖いでしょ」
うっうわっ！
風で揺れてませんか！？
揺れてますよ！？
うぅわっ！
うわっ！うわうわうわうわ
（ちなみにオイシイみかんは
にしうわ！　うわっ！by字幕編集者）
うぅわっ！
うわ～～～～～～～～～～～～！！
うわーっ！
３，２，１
バンジー！
マサキ「怖かった？」
はじめ「こぉわいよぉ～」
とりあえず一回目だと
全然まだまだです
じゃ2回目いってきます
マサキ「はい、いってらっしゃい！」
は「二回目は行けそうです！」
マ「ほんとかよｗ」
2回目行ってきます！
こわっ！
何にも変わらん！（なんでや～）
ねなんで？なんでなんでなんで？
こえーこえー
３，２，１
バンジー！
うわーっ！
はぁ～っ！
あぁああ！
はぁあぁぁぁぁあああああ！
ああああああああああああああ！
目開けてもこわい！！
ま「ど、どうだった？」
は「思ったよりもこわかったっす」
ただいまハーネスが睾丸に当たって凄い。。。
までも、あとは数をやっていくしかないですね
（注：回数を重ねていくしかない
と言いたかったのでしょう。）
3回目いってきます！！
ま「怖くなくなるのかどうかもわかんないけどね」
こわいよぉ～～
やっぱこわいねぇ
３，２，１
バンジー！
こわいよぉぉぉおおお
うわぁぁああああああ
うわぁ
ぁあ
あぁ
ぁあ！
おぉぉぉぉぉおおおおー！
待って睾丸がやばい、、、
睾丸が、、、
待って！待って！
睾丸がぁああ
恐怖心より睾丸の痛さがすごかった
たぶんポジションが・・・ｗ
なんか精神が
擦り切れてきた。。。
さぁ4回目行きます
ま「余裕？」
いや怖いわｗ
全然怖いわ(-_-;)
３，２，１
バンジー！
ヴゥォアアアアアア！！
ゥアアアアア！
ォルルァァアア！
もう合計だって88m落ちてるからね
ま「5回目　いってらっしゃい」
３，２，１
バンジー！
ああ！怖いぃヨォォ！
全然怖いよ！！
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁ
（元兵庫県議員）
いや睾丸が熱い。。。
ヤバい
精巣がもうおかしくなってくるｗ
生物学的な危機を
感じております
もう1回行ってきますわ
ま「6回目」
は「6回目行ってきます」
はぁい　　　　はぁい
はぁーいいきまーす（棒）
はぁい
はーい
３，２，１
バンジー！
あぁぁぁぁ～
ア''ア''ア''ア''ア''！！（睾丸）
マジでやばいかも
ま「恐怖心と睾丸の痛みどっちが上？」
睾丸！
だってあぁぁって落ちてきたじゃん？
あぁぁぁって言ったの睾丸の痛みだからね
ま「怖さじゃなくて？ｗ」
は「ほんとにほんとに　結構いたい」
ま「まじで？
インタビュー（↑）
初ですか！？
もう一回頑張ってきます！
よし
行ってきます
・・・２，１
バンジー！
あぁあ
ヌワッ！
イテェ！！
え？なにがつらいかって？
ジャンプしたときの「うわぁぁぁあああ」とか
毎回毎回大変だったよ
もぉはじめん字幕のことも考えてっ！ｗ
次回
はじめしゃちょー→
睾丸摘出手術
というわけで今回の字幕は
お久しぶり「AKT　あく」でしたｗ